this morning we are remembering an icon
of American cinema Kirk Douglas was one
of the last surviving movie stars of the
classic Hollywood era that emerged after
World War two he was admired for his
looks his very good looks and respected
for his intensity vladimir duthiers is
here to show us Douglass's remarkable
career Vlad remarkable is just one of
the adjectives we could use to describe
Kirk Douglas today legendary dashing
amazing Spartacus he starred in more
than 80 films Gale in announcing his
death his son Michael Douglas wrote to
the world he was a legend an actor from
the Golden Age of movies who lived well
into his golden years but to me and my
brothers he was simply dad but there was
only one Spartacus and just one Kirk
Douglas he was born easier
Danijela vich to russian immigrant
parents in 1916 he changed his name to
Kirk Douglas after serving in the Navy
in World War two and not long after that
I remember he secured his first movie
role in the strange love of Martha Ivers
but his breakout performance was as
boxer Mitch Kelley in champion for the
first time in my life people cheering
for me for me he'd go on to star as a
greedy movie mogul a jazz musician
a Western gunslinger a French army
commander in World War one and so much
more but for years Douglass had a
reputation as someone who was difficult
to work with because I'm a loner care
down deep to my very guts in 1992 60
minutes correspondent Mike Wallace asked
him why where did that all come from
Kirk showed you what a good actor I am
because I really am the sweetest Douglas
Warren an honorary Oscar in 1996 thank
you for his years as a force in the film
community he lived to be 103 what is old
add or a dog dies at 14 and tortoises
live over a hundred now let me say Mike
the poet's say grow old along with me
their best is yet to be indeed Kirk
Douglas was also known as a generous
philanthropist donating money to
hospitals and scholarships earlier we
showed you a scene from Spartacus on
that film he also showed courage
off-screen helping break the Hollywood
blacklist by crediting a banned
screenwriter Dalton Dalton Trumbo yes
and he made that film with his own
production company he started his own
production company in the 50s sparked
first and made Spartacus and at a time
when he said the system was basically
slavery yes studios just a legend
thank you very much we'll see you a bit
later